got to listen to this how do you not
want to hear leslie jordan with eddie
vetter you have to get this
immediately i know i am right after this
leslie jordan
with dolly parton i mean how are you not
star struck
when you meet dolly parton well you're
beyond star struck because the first
thing you think that
she might be a little bit of a joke or
something she's a she's as smart as a
she's as smart as a whip and she looks
right at you
and talks to you and it she's she's
everything you think she would be that
little tiny waist and that
butt she's got this little butt
dolly party she's 75 years old
and looks like a million dollars and she
has been dolly since the 50s
you know how these girls have changed
their hairdos and their hair styles and
put the skirts up the skirts down to
this that not dolly
she found her look and she's been with
it and she's so smart
and so good you know they're just people
that are just
good she's still to this day at 75 years
old still can sing
i told her i said dolly i went and saw
you in 1973. she said you did not you
made that up
i said no i did i said i live in
chattanooga tennessee
you were up in seville tennessee you
sang at the high school auditorium she
said
that was the year jolene came out and i
did sing at the high school auditorium
but you weren't there you made that up
and i said
uh okay i'm gonna give you opening line
hey everybody i'm dolly parton
what's a country girl without her
haystack
cause she let your
but what's it like when you're singing
with her when you're well you don't get
to sing anymore with people because of
code but i don't know if it's
the future of the recording industry but
you lay your track down
right the closest i got was to tanya on
one of my songs i got tonya tucker we
were
in in the studio but we were separated
by glass
um i didn't get anywhere near eddie he
was in hawaii like his down there
um i didn't get anywhere near randy
carlisle or
well hang on a second do you lay your
vocals down first and then they go in
or was it vice versa the reason that we
do that i think is so that they can
because they're the better singer i
think really they can do more
with harmony and this and that and then
but there's a lot of going back and
forth like i'll go back in
dolly tall the whole time well in this
way don't you love this leslie and i had
to go back in and answer her
she talked and then she loved her
i'm on my way and then she taught you
they said this is so much on these hands
make me feel good and
blah blah but her whole family's thing
on my side on my album
my album's for winter and wait a minute
and so she'll talk then you'll go back
in the studio and you have to write
something that sounds kind of
conversational i have to just
answer her answer whatever she said or
what
it's amazing what those engineers can do
man wow
they can find that one there's a lot of
auto tune going on
um dolly even said to me at one time
dolly said now listen when i can't when
when my family and i were doing this
there's one where i did
my own harmony so when we do this live
we will have to get someone from the
back up to
i said this light it had never
crossed my mind that i might stand on a
stick
well you might be going to the grand old
opry sometime again and singing with her
i just said oh my god dolly and
and so uh we'll see we'll see
see i'm not a good singer i'm a hand
singer i'm just a hen singer i grew up
singing hymns and there's a way which
like my mother said leslie just sing out
for the lord
that's all you care about you just
singing for the lord
so you didn't care you just went and
went back and just let it out
can you give me a little bit of i'm
working on a building for my lord that
you're saying from the grand ole opry
i've been working on the building if i
wasn't
tell you what i do i just keep online
and start working on the building do
i'm working on